[Music]
welcome to earbiscus the podcast for two
lifelong friends talk about life for a
long time I'm red and I'm link this week
at the round table of dim lighting I
have no clue
what you're going to talk about
I'm back man you're back
um one of the things that I I do want to
talk about I didn't tell you about this
was um you know reached a big milestone
with uh my second child Lincoln uh
sending them out of the house sending
him off to college yep but he doesn't
get a full podcast about it because you
know he's the second one he's a middle
child absolutely but I I hadn't I hadn't
told you about the details of it did
something specific that happened that um
walking around crying even crying with
it well I'm I will say that uh I
embarrassed myself in front of oh you
the faculty oh oh so that's my teaser uh
what do you want what do you want to
talk about well I know you talked about
uh your trip I have just a little tidbit
from my trip that I that I want to talk
about uh you you're talking about your
solo camping trip that I explained in
the last episode that we had tandem solo
camping trips yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
didn't really talk about yours except
for like the 10 to 10 minute meeting
that we had in the middle of not ever
seeing anyone else for five days uh yeah
so I'll talk a little bit about that
I'll tell you where I've been and why I
kind of sound like I sound right now
yeah well you still I mean you still
sound sick
uh I'm not everybody knows that you've
been sick but I mean you're you're still
sick
uh I'm not sick in the way I'm not sick
in the way that matters I'm I've just
been through I've been through a battle
I've been through a week-long battle and
so my body is just like well we haven't
completely uh what about me having to
carry all the weight here at mythical
well Jenna was here yeah I think you're
okay yeah you're right she pretty much
carried the weight and I think you she's
not here today I think it's either one
or the other to leave after after doing
this podcast with you she had to leave
town no she did leave town but um you
should be threatened I'm just going to
tell you that uh and I also when she
comes back I might I need to make a
tough choice okay I also have an update
for you uh one of the things that I did
while I was sick was I watched a lot of
programming as I like to say as a old
man
I never watch television anymore and I
don't want and I watch movies
occasionally but like I just never sit
down and binge a show like I mean I did
that's something I did 15 years ago
maybe but I just don't have time for it
anymore so Silver Lining I watched an
entire season of a television show in
one day wow don't if your eyes get any
bigger I might let some germs in uh and
I'll talk to you about that show and I'm
gonna tell you when I learned oh we're
still in teaser mode about uh about
something because it applies to you and
I think it it elucidates
something that happened to you that
you've talked about on this podcast
before okay but I'll start let me I'll
start with the just a quick update on
what I experienced on the solo trip most
notably
um
was
I was as you know you probably already
thought about the fact that I found an
incredible campsite that then you
enjoyed for a couple of days you didn't
listen to my podcast without you it
hasn't even come out yet
but no I'm not going to listen to it
so no on both counts uh it's it was it
was really good I thought I'm sure it
was and I'm sure I'll see inevitably I
thought I got great feedback I'm sure
inevitably confronted with clips from it
in various forms of social media that
the algorithm thinks that I'm interested
in the algorithm thinks that I'm
interested in mythical content and when
I see it I'm like
how should I tell what should I tell the
algorithm about this
you know what I'm saying should I tell I
mean we kind of have a vested interest
oh I always like it
if something mythical comes in the
algorithm I'll heart it and move on
because I'm like what does that tell the
algorithm that he likes it but he
doesn't like it to watch a lot of it
yeah I think you actually need to watch
it
but what's one guy gonna do I feel like
by liking it and moving on I'm just
keeping I'm not contributing to it
right negatively or positively okay well
I never saw it
so
that campsite that I found uh yeah so
beautiful it was the best campsite I've
ever seen one of them yeah I thought I
was giving you a solid when we when we
camp swapped
you want to give me a you want me to
give you a campsite review on your
campsite I know it wasn't as good but it
was there wasn't enough cloud cover to
give you a stunning Sunset I'm just
gonna be honest with you on a scale of
one to ten with the sunset that I could
see through the trees the night that you
got to enjoy the sunset that campsite's
a 10. nine okay nine yeah
without the sunset because that Sunset
didn't happen the next day because I
don't know how sunsets work
but I kept watching it and just waiting
for it to do the beautiful it was a
cloud barrage of colors that had
happened the night before you missed out
man and I was like it's not gonna happen
it's not gonna happen I was like well
maybe it happened I literally sat there
and I was like maybe it happens right
before the sun goes down and then I just
kind of watch the sun go away and I was
like maybe it happens right after the
sun goes down and I was we were having
like opposite expenses sitting there
looking at it thinking you were having
the most disappointing that campsite's a
four when the sun went down right just
being honest with you it's a four you
sent me to a four hey man I did the best
I could
um
but while I was at that wonderful
campsite
uh actually the ACT not the first night
I I spent there but when I woke up and I
was lying on the rock
overlooking that Lake yeah yeah you're
talking about the the the the great
campsite
yeah
um
I was listening to some uh synth music
you know
so many genres synth music I was
listening to that uh Mort Garson oh yeah
he's great and uh he's a synth pioneer
and
I it's the music is Whimsical it's weird
and Whimsical depends on what album
you're on but I I was listening to it
and then I would notice like like this
dissonant synth
that he put into one of the songs I was
like oh that's an interesting choice
Mort interesting choice dissonance
hmm
and then the next song rolled around I
was like uh there's another dissonance
synth
have I never noticed these dissonance
synths that seem ill-timed out of
nowhere okay third song rolls around
it happens again I'm like that's and I
turned the music off and I wait
and then I hear oh coming from the
[__] van dissonance it was the van
now
it actually I have like it makes me feel
weird when I talk about it because it
was so jarring to me and it really
impacted my entire trip
something happened when you're alone
it all bets are off
in terms of how any anomaly can be taken
processed it didn't scare me but it
annoyed me and it was pretty damn loud
and it turns out that it was the coming
from where in the van
the automatic awning
yeah you push the button e awning goes
out right and I bit you know what
so there's a Winston and if you drive if
you drive off with the awning out the
awning will go in and if a big win comes
up well as soon as you just crank the
car the van up it automatically closed
yeah because you don't want to be
driving down the street with an awning
out by accident but if a big gust of
wind comes up
it'll sense that and go in too yeah so
it's pretty smart there is a a motion
detector on the edge of the awning
precisely to detect wind and then to
bring it in
and because it was out in a little and
there wasn't a lot of wind on that trip
I mean it was crazy the weather was
super hot but it was also not very windy
on top of a mountain which was unusual
but a little wind that day
and it caused it to go off but then it
started going every 30 seconds
eventually I read the manual and learned
that it said that it was the batteries
needed to be replaced in the motion
sensor which by the way I did replace
and it didn't stop oh wow you had to you
went deep you had batteries to replace
it uh I took two batteries out of uh
like a flashlight that I had two two
double a batteries MacGyver I like
literally there's some old men uh hiking
that trail where right when I was gonna
when I met you and we had our little
Rendezvous yeah Rendezvous we didn't get
out of the car no it made it sound like
we like went to a campsite and you know
no fondled one another but that's not
what happened uh it didn't sound like
that no I'm just trying to feed the
rumors that's I'm just making sure yeah
I just I mean there's people out there
who live their life I barely hung out
the window wanting to believe that we
had a rendezvous barely made eye contact
with you I know I looked at your dog
more than you but I'm just I'm
interested in making those people I want
them clicking I can't they got to keep
clicking I'm trying to give this thing a
title
so fondling Rendezvous so we're so
desperate uh we went to that bull tree
the bull tree Trail yes and I've already
talked all about it you should have
listened to the podcast and the old man
was not out we're there and uh they and
I was like hey guys you have a
screwdriver I I was like I'm going a
little bit crazy here this thing's
making this noise like it was so loud
that like as my van was parked in a
parking lot with like two other people I
was like kind of embarrassed and now as
I began to walk that trail I was like
how deep into the woods am I going to
get before I stopped hearing my van's
noise
and you may live the rest of your life
and first of all I'm out of service like
I don't have cell service in any of
these spots and I and I was like I'm
gonna replace the batteries myself I
replace the batteries the sound never
went away I had to put earplugs in for
two nights oh to sleep and eventually on
the way back home
is when the sound stopped
with no explanation
uh I don't know I think it was a second
I think it was a short now oh you know
what don't listen
to the previous podcast where I gushed
about how amazing my solo trip was how
life-changing it was how I I can't stop
thinking about how I want to experience
it again it's my new happy place that I
close my eyes and picture I'm happy for
you I'm happy for you don't I but I
don't want to rub it in
um
well with or without the sound I would
not have had that experience because
uh I mean I guess this is going to serve
as my ear biscuits announcement I don't
know when I'll talk about this on my own
social media or whatever but uh you know
I do a little music on the side as James
and the shame and I didn't really expect
this to happen this year but a couple of
things fell into place and I've got a a
little EP that's coming out in November
James and shame is back with an Eep and
how many songs is that uh well
technically six or less and right now it
looks like it is going to be six
uh we've got five completely mixed and
mastered in nursing Honda is where we're
dialing it in there's some type we're
trying to figure some stuff out however
a little teaser I mean someone you may
or may not know
that may or may not be in this room May
uh may I don't know may have been
involved in one of the tracks uh that's
pretty exciting uh more on that later
yeah but the first track someone who's
known for his beatboxing skills yeah yep
exactly all the drums on the entire
entire EP are from Elk count snuggle
mouth
um
ironically the the project is called
Nothing Left to love I'll talk about
this I'm not I don't you know I don't
think for the follow-up EP you do a
whole podcast or in the listening party
and that was kind of like that was like
the first go-round but I'll probably
talk about this in in different pieces
or whatever talk about it as different
things come out but nothing left to look
nothing left to love which is the name
of that first track that uh oh yeah that
you've that you've heard other than the
one that you may or may not be involved
with
um which I and that's the first thing
that's the first single but also the
name of the EP
I don't know I don't know what
convention is and I don't really care
and so I just kind of do it what feels
right and so the name of the EP is
nothing left to love that's also the
name of the first single so
um
because
it's basically a it's it's basically
sort of like an Ode to Enneagram threes
you know performance minded people
people who are just doing stuff and
they're just trying to do more and more
stuff and they don't know exactly why
they're trying to they're trying to fill
the empty void Inside by doing stuff
okay um achieving things with this with
this that lyric will make sense I'll
talk about it later anyway so the ironic
thing is is that
this whole album is kind of an example
of that it's just like why do and why do
more I don't know I can't help myself
and so I just did it and here it is and
I'm throwing it out there whatever
but then what I did is I turned my solo
trip into a work trip in which I was
going to film myself singing some of
these songs out in these beautiful
locations uh spoiler alert at least for
that first track I don't think any of
the stuff I shot for the first song is
gonna work because I just couldn't ever
sing it right it's not an easy song for
me to sing like a lot it was a live
performance not lip sync stuff yeah yeah
it's like you know it's kind of a tick
tock Trend that I actually I'm kind of
into is just like people setting up a
microphone like in the wilderness and
singing a song and I was like oh this is
actually kind of a Cool vibe for this
album and so
um so a lot you told me you were gonna
do this
and I was like I was a little bummed for
you I mean I was happy for you that this
was coming out and that you had this
time just with you and your guitar and I
guess your camera and your your beeping
van to like
you know to to uh
cover your own songs
but I was like okay yeah so now your
solo trip is not it becomes a work it I
I think it's going to feel different so
I was a little
bummed for you but this is I was
concerned for this is the rub this is
the rub
what am I going to go into this such a
beautiful location
and I'm not going to make a special trip
for this because my job is what we do at
mythical my job isn't my music it's my
side project and so it fits it wasn't
going to take all your time anyway no
but because I haven't shot
video and a lot like the only video that
we've shot everything takes is like the
Vlogs Yeah Yeah from a couple years ago
which now we even made the decision to
not do that and just let you know other
folks shoot that and but I got this new
camera which I'm gonna you know I am
excited about this okay so you okay so
you know that uh
I bought that Pentax for like a hundred
bucks or whatever I don't like the the
film camera yeah we would develop the
film and I've still got like four or
five undeveloped rolls of film because
it's like it's a pain in the ass to get
film developed and then I stopped taking
it with me on trips because I had to
like get the guy at the TSA to like put
take a bag and not take the film through
the new machines and stuff oh but I
really love photography and I was like I
wanna I wanna be able to take cool
pictures that was a layer it was a layer
oh well it was a phase yo no no that is
ended no no it hasn't film camera phase
is over no it isn't because I started
watching all these YouTube videos and I
started and I and so I started learning
about Fuji film cameras right and and
when I say Fujifilm I mean Fujifilm the
brand and so they've got these and I'm
this is for those people who like know
about this stuff I'm just gonna sound
like a nimwit but uh
a dim yeah a nimrod or a dim with it no
you sound like a Nimble a nimwit
um I know nothing so so they have these
film recipes essentially where people
have figured out how to uh well Fuji
also contributes to this basically their
settings on the camera and then people
have like dialed them in in very
specific ways to like mimic very
particular films and you can get really
close to like oh if you were to shoot on
film with this film it's not perfect but
if you're just me and you're just going
for Vibes what do you say emulate films
you're not talking about like
Dr Zhivago you're talking about specific
film stocks film stocks okay so like
portrait are 100 or whatever okay and so
I've been experimenting you're losing me
but also it has some really cool
settings for shooting uh video that look
very cinematic in a way that just like
Got a Cool vibe so I shot everything I
shot was in that kind of like filmic
Vibe but you know just because I've got
the camera out and I have a very little
bit of battery I'm going to I got a
setting on here uh it's called Uh 70s
summer I'm going to take uh I'm going to
take some 70s summer shot because by the
way what should I do uh I'm gonna be I'm
gonna I'm getting back into taking more
photos Okay a lot of my photos will be
of you okay uh because you're here
and uh just so you know so just do just
do cool stuff make cool faces uh yeah
that's oh that's cool okay there's a
little too much white on your shirt you
know kind of look more pensive
uh I'm leaning back
yeah maybe I'll be forward action shot
oh yeah okay that's it prayer oh that's
well I can only let me switch that up
that's
wow I'm I'm praying but do I have a
double chin when I pray I Don't Wanna
do it again press more
okay and I got a different setting here
let me go to that let me go to my you
see I have a black and white negative
setting whichever which is kind of crazy
it's crazy what this one looks like and
I'm gonna act like I'm
covering up the lens
oh that was a cool shot
again
okay now just pensive again
Pray Again
pray again yeah you're praying in black
and white now
dear God let's let him get done with
this quickly because I'm bored out of my
mind okay I got some good shots okay
you're gonna be impressed with that okay
maybe what we'll do is we'll just put
them right here in the in the yeah look
at that immediate gratification that's
even if you're watching if you're
watching this is all about game videos
so you took this camera always think
about strategy you guys I took pictures
of you yes so that the people who just
listened will be like well now I gotta
watch yeah two two double views double
views
um
but
when that sound happened
I was starting to listening to it I was
like I think it's happening
at a pretty predictable
rate I think I don't know how many
seconds it is but so I just like I was
kind of going nuts I got my guitar out
because you didn't have a dog that would
have helped
no a dog would have been a nightmare in
this situation when you're trying to
film yourself yeah that's true so I
start playing and I kind of time out
like
a certain pace
in a chord structure that will
predictably have spaces for this sound
okay and to embrace it and it felt like
like a
you know this sort of lemonade out of
lemon yeah exactly so I wrote a song and
I was like this song If I this this song
about this beep is probably going to get
more traction than any of my actual
music you know what I'm saying he wrote
a song about the beat so I wrote a song
about the beat which will be released at
some point I mean not as like a I mean
it'll just be on my social media or
whatever again it's all about playing a
game link you gotta get people to care
about it's all about achieving it's yeah
exactly ironically
um so anyway that was what my that was I
think I actually learned quite a bit I
journaled quite a bit did you Journal uh
a little
a jotted I would not call it journaling
more of a summary
because
I
you know man it's just like I'm
continuing the thing that therapy has
allowed me to do I've always known that
I've been you know everybody's a little
bit messed up but I've always known that
a dim Rod nimwit yeah
I've always known that I've got issues
that you know everybody's got issues who
gotta work through throughout your life
but is it is it time for the better
health migration I think that therapy
gave me tools to you to like go up to
the proverbial battery compartment in
your awning and unscrew it yes do you
know what I'm saying so yeah it gives
you some tools so
I think that's one of the things that
the the trip was able to do for me I was
like this trip is so emblematic of the
way that I approach things which is like
you got a little bit of time yes you're
relaxing but this is also a great
opportunity for you to do the things
that you need to do for this thing that
you've signed yourself up for that no
one asked you to do right no one asked
for well so okay some people ask for
more music I will say that there are
people who ask for more music but that
but this whole thing has been about me
doing stuff for for me you know like the
price I felt like these songs were in
there I gotta I gotta get them out but
still I found a way to turn it into work
and then
this
yeah started happening and I was like
what does that
what does that beep represent it you
know and I'm still I'm still thinking
I'm still figuring out what it
represents but I did write a song about
it uh it's the nine reality that you
still have work to do
well and so do I but we we basically in
totally different ways we have the same
experience of
getting in touch with ourselves and like
for me experiencing the Perfection of
my campsite and my environment exposed
my dependence on that so you know there
was a lot of self-exploration
that I think you were having you know we
were both having well I think the thing
that I ended up writing down now that
I'm thinking about it was
this beep
what it symbolizes to me is that
you come up here to the mountains to be
alone
to get away from everything to get away
from everyone
but you're still with yourself
you know what I'm saying wherever you go
there you are and yourself is
not it's I mean it's not something that
you in a mini senses it's not something
that you like it's something that comes
with
issues and things that you gotta deal
with you know what I'm saying like if
you're being honest with yourself you
got a lot of [__] that you brought up
here besides this van that's messing up
just the guy that came up here with me
which is me it got a lot of [__] that he
brought
and it's just on display for myself
yeah in this place
I'm glad you're able to turn the
frustration into some sort of meaning
you were able to Pivot and not just be
miserable I mean you were you were
miserable in a sense but not
as miserable as you could have been you
know you used it
yeah it now
it like even the next more like I went
to sleep that night with those uh you
know like the uh the wax I luckily had
wax earplugs oh wow which you Hey listen
if you're having trouble sleeping you
got a partner that snores you got people
upstairs in your apartment building that
make a lot of noise
you can do the I don't know what a whack
you can do the noise
the foam you know the foam ear plugs
but when you go to the foam earplugs
section of your local pharmacy
there will also be
these clear
ish wax earplugs
and there'll be a pack of them because
you're I mean you probably shouldn't use
them more than once or I don't know how
often you should use them but they're
like you put them in hot water first no
no they're soft wax
and you take you do the reach around you
pull on your ear you take one of these
suckers well you roll it out and make it
a little bit flat and then you stick it
I mean long it's like putting a Tootsie
Roll in your ear and then you press it
down and it completely conforms to the
exact shape of your ear canal
how do you get it out well it does say
warning if you push these too hard they
may be difficult to get out but I've
never had a problem with it no the still
there's still so much wax that it's like
sticking out bro these things
you can't hear anything like Bax
murderer could have been just gnawing on
the side of the van and not even without
no idea oh that would be a meth addict
yeah so
I highly recommend these they're way I
don't know how many decibels but it's
way more than the foam ones is it such
that like you're hearing like your
internal processes like that's
off-putting to me when I'm like I don't
think so I'm like here heartbeat yeah
hearing your heartbeat swallow yeah
hearing like your eyes move yeah your
eyes move in the sockets no none of that
none of that happened none of that
happened and I could also just like jump
in a creek and not worry about getting
worms in my ears
I you got to get these wax wax plugs
okay okay all right fine
I I jotted down
one of the things was just preparing for
the fact that Lincoln was leaving
so I do want to talk about that I do
want to mention first of all that we
have new mugs we got a new season of
Good Mythical Morning new season you
know what that means new mug this it's
it's the classic GMM on that side but
then as it goes around here take a look
at that can you believe it and not only
is that a super cool design
it's the cockatrice
blowing the flame of Good Mythical
Morning in a landscape configuration
it's glow-in-the-dark it's freaking
glowing the freaking dark
and
um that's going to help you get it to
your mouth
in the blackout
which is an inevitably coming
mythical.com get yourself some of that
ear biscus is supported by a Rosetta
Stone you know sometimes I just feel
very very American in the fact that I
can only speak one in one English one
English one language and that is English
you know I just I'm just not as
interesting as I could be link let's
just be honest and you said it man uh
not just for this for the utility of it
it would be nice to speak another
language to you know fluently
communicate with other people mostly
it's about the way people would think
about me if I were able to speak another
language is this how Rosetta Stone wants
us to I mean I think Rosetta Stone cares
how like why you want to learn they just
they want to provide a way for you to
learn if you do Rosetta Stone is the
most trusted language learning program
and it truly immerses you in the
language you want to learn for whatever
reasons you want to learn it they've
used trusted experts for 30 years with
millions of users and 25 languages
offered including French Spanish Chinese
Japanese Dutch Arabic polish just to
name a few it also immerses you in many
ways designed for long-term retention
there are no English translations so you
really learn to speak listen and think
in that language plus they have a
built-in true accent feature that gives
you feedback on your pronunciation like
having a personal trainer for your
accent that's cool and it's an amazing
value a lifetime membership that's a
lifetime membership has all 25 languages
for any and all language needs in your
life it's a 299 dollar program but with
our code you can get it for just a
hundred and seventy nine dollars don't
put off learning that language there's
no better time than right now to get
started for a very limited time you can
get Rosetta Stone's lifetime membership
for 40 off that's 179 dollars for
unlimited access to 25 language courses
for the rest of your life redeem your 40
off at rosettastone.com ear today
earbiscus is supported by thrive Market
whenever I go to the grocery store and
I'm like trying to get something and
then I'm looking at the different prices
for the different types of the same
thing
I I get overwhelmed man and I still
don't know if I'm getting the best price
or the best thing
that's where Thrive marketing it sounds
like you need the right marketing I I it
really does doesn't it well Thrive
Market is one of my go-to's for when I
need organic grocery and household
essentials and the convenience of
getting it all quickly shipped to my
doorstep is a huge Time Saver I save
money every time I order I think I saved
like fifty dollars last time I used it
the chomp beef sticks we have in the
office are so much cheaper through
Thrive than at the store on top of the
massive savings on each order Thrive
Market has a deals page that changes
daily and gives cash back on so many
Brands and they have a price match
guarantee not only does thrive markets
Thrive I like how you said thrive thrive
Market save me money but they also save
me time I love the filters on their
website or app they have over 70 whether
you're looking for certified gluten-free
snacks or non-toxic cleaning Essentials
you can curate your own shopping
experience with the click of a button
one of my favorite Parts is that when
you join Thrive Market you're also
helping a family in need with their one
for one membership matching program you
join they give join in on the savings
with Thrive market today and get 30 off
your first order plus a free 60 gift go
to thrivemarket.com ear for 30 off your
first order plus a free 60 gift that's
t-h-r-i-v-e market.com slash ear
thrivemarket.com ear
did you think about that while you were
out there that about like the collapse
of civilization no no
I did it's not one of the problems that
I was trying to tackle I just can't help
it when I'm out there and I'm alone I
just can't help but think like man
what'd I do if like everything ended
while I was up here I was emotionally
processing or emotionally preparing for
um at the time it was just like a few
weeks later and now it's happened uh
taking Lincoln off to college and
um
when we took Lily and dropped it off for
college there's a couple of things first
of all it was still like during the
pandemic and like
there was I didn't I didn't realize that
a typical taking your kid off to college
there's like programmatic stuff that the
university usually like invites you to
and like when you dropped off lock like
you you as a parent showed up for
different things and like right we did a
little bit well there was a lot of that
for Lincoln and I was wasn't expecting
it because there was none of that for
Lily and it was just you know the other
thing is it is a somewhat school
specific as well okay yeah that's
probably true
um the other thing was and you know I
talked about it extensively
at this table was I was
convinced I I was
fully giving myself to processing
emotionally Lily leaving and like so
yeah there was like that night of like a
lot of crying alone and just thinking
about
what like what a momentous occasion this
was and everything that it meant and
what it might mean for the future of our
relationship and that type of stuff
um it was rewarding I honestly I found
myself thinking
I felt more prepared uh I didn't feel as
emotionally volatile
this time around and then I started to
feel bad about that
and I was like man is is it is that is
the middle child thing happening where
it's like okay second one yeah doesn't
I'm not as worked up about this
emotionally and then I've still got one
at home
you know
They Don't Really represent as much as
the first kid or the last kid leaving
well there is a lot to that middle kid
thing and you know he's he's he's
weathered all that like a champ
but then I started to realize that that
wasn't really the reason why I wasn't as
emotional it was definitely a part of it
like everything wasn't new
but the experience that I've had with
with Lily since moving her in
has had a profound impact on how I
approached this
um I've seen Lily a lot she's been back
quite a few she's been she's she's come
back home a good a good amount and I've
gone to see her we've gone to see her
it's not like I I think I was afraid and
thought that you know the nature of our
relationship was going to change when
she moved out to the point where
like the our relationship would be so
much less
but actually even though there's a lot
more distance and there hasn't been
nearly as
much quantity of time together
the quality of the time that we've had
together I would say has increased and
more than uh superseded
like how we worked before like how our
relationship worked so I actually
experience the fact that like
we continue to grow and we have a lot of
valuable experiences together and our
relationship is still very vibrant and
she's still a very connected part of our
family and
I don't think I I I expected that to
happen I was mourning the loss of
something that I actually didn't lose
and that totally informed and made me
once I realized it I started to feel
better to the point where I actually
told Lincoln I'm like you may have
noticed that I haven't been
as worked up as I was when Lily left and
I want you to know that I've realized
that it doesn't have as much to do with
you being the middle child or or
certainly that I that I love you less or
and feel or feel less connected to you
than I do to Lily it has nothing to do
with that it's that the experience he
said that I I haven't noticed all right
yeah he wasn't like I'm an 18 year old
guy right
yeah that is kind of what his response
was uh he was like it's cool it's it's
cool dad I know that you care about me
and that you're you're engaged in what's
happening with with me leaving but it
really did alter the complexion of how I
approached it you know I was able to be
a a lot happier a lot more excited for
Lincoln
than I was for Lily you know because I
think I was a lot more sad for myself
with with the with the first one you
know so uh we take Lincoln we take him
down there and then we had packed up
everything but like the first day was
like programmatic stuff like there's a
there's a all the freshmen and their
parents like go in this place and like
you hear from the president of the
university and then there's like these
information sessions and then we split
up and the parents have like a mixer and
then and the students have their own
separate thing and it was like a lot so
much so that it was like the second day
when we showed up that we actually moved
him into his dorm room met his roommates
and all of that stuff and so that first
night before we moved him in
we were invited to a smaller Gathering
where we had the opportunity to meet the
president of the university and some of
the Deans of the different colleges
and um this is when you embarrass
yourself it was like yeah it was like a
mixer yeah and um you didn't have to go
to this
uh we were excited to go to it and
Lando was there Christy was there me and
Lincoln were there we were kind of like
semi-dressed up we want to put on you
know put your best foot forward okay
he's already in though he's already wait
you know you want to make a good
impression with the dean
of of his college and stuff like skid
steer still respect college dean
um
I had a bar but I would you know I
wasn't I wasn't like drinking it's not
like I got shit-faced
I I I I got a Diet Coke okay and then
Lily and Chrissy were sitting down and
then one of the like the head of
um I don't know what her title is but
she's like the main person in charge of
like the liaison between like incoming
students their parents and like
maintaining that connection like she was
she was introducing me to another Dean
Lincoln and I to another Dean and two
seniors who were
like basically in a club that
you know they talked up their college
experience and so I got you got to meet
us some seniors you got to meet a Dean
you got to meet this this woman who's
like uh moving and shaking and bringing
everybody into the University
and we're so we're we're talking in a
circle
and
um it was going great
and I would you know I was have I was
like
saying something and I was really into
it and so my left hand Lincoln was to my
left and then the uh
the head of the the thing that I don't
know her title she was she was to his
left and and I'm holding with my left
hand my diet coke and I'm gesturing with
my right hand yeah I gotta figure it out
for a second and so here my here my
right hand is gesturing you clip the cup
through my left hand and it's it's like
they were it's like they don't
communicate with the same brain or
something yeah yeah there's definitely a
block in there well I think it's
biblical don't let your right hand know
what your left hand is doing yeah that's
about masturbation no it's not it's
about it's about it's about giving money
I never told the other man
that's how God finds out none of them
get jealous God looks at the other hand
so my right hand didn't know that left
hand was holding a full glass of Diet
Coke and just and gestured in an upward
sweeping motion and you were talking
all all eyes on me and I'm like doof and
I just send this thing flying
right at my son's crotch oh that's
better than the dean's crush and then it
splatters all off of his crotch
onto a little bit of the dean oh a
little bit of the dean a little bit of
the dean but it was Diet Coke it was a
Diet Coke it wasn't regular Coke it
wasn't a real problem it wasn't red wine
we'd have ants it was a red wine but he
had on like and then I'm like oh you
know and how'd you recover it's a pretty
embarrassing moment well I I was like
you ran out I don't know what I said
um but I think it was something like
whoops oh
and I was like what did Lincoln do you I
oh okay I know Lincoln
he the first of all Lincoln's too sweet
to get
upset in the moment about it or maybe to
get upset at all about it
he probably was like dang that yeah that
was pretty much it pretty much he was
like
and I'm like looking over I'm like
grabbing a stack full of napkins from
the bar and I'm like dabbing my son's
crotch in front of the dean why don't
you hand him the napkins I did I don't
know man because I was like this is
where you're I was like and I was
thinking you know what this is this is
an opportunity for me to demonstrate
this is an opportunity for me to
demonstrate how caring I am how to
recover from an embarrassing moment you
got to keep your cool you got to be a
little self-deprecating I'm like well
look at look at what I've done here and
um then the like the senior
is like coming in and bringing in more
napkins and mopping up oh he has like an
assigned senior
well he was in the group he was the guy
talking okay to us you should have given
the senior the napkins yeah and at that
point I was like well uh I'm putting you
to work
that's what I said how much coke was
left I'm putting you to work how early
in the drinking phase was it was uh very
early
there's a lot of coke down there
and and um I just really think it took
the pressure off Lincoln to have to you
know yeah I was you know I was trying to
make it no so yeah trying to make it
easier on him that's what it was about
but taking taking the brunt of
the embarrassment the old gesture with
one hand and hit something in another
hand I mean that's a special kind of
thing it's like the last I was I was I
was like because if you just watch
somebody do that and you weren't
listening it just looks like somebody
goes it's like that had to be
intentional you know it's like yeah yeah
let's let's watch the replay on that one
yeah apparently his left hand doesn't
know what his right hand's doing
um you know I just I was already a
little bit concerned about you know
those environments and I don't want
people to know me
I don't want to be the one who's
recognized and was like this is about
Lincoln and right this is about I want
to do anything to draw any attention to
yourself right right
and uh so Lincoln was very gracious he
he didn't he didn't he never left about
the dean what did the dean say
you know they were all gracious oh
really and I did you know I kept my
poise I was just like you know it
happens yeah man it happens sorry about
that figure out me long enough it'll
happen again
yeah yeah I mean at least it wasn't and
so I was like you know what and then the
conversation and then I continued the
conversation open the door well it's I
just moved on and I was like you know
what the best thing I can do is
demonstrate to my son and anybody else
who's watching which is everybody
apparently that you just gotta pick up
the pieces or stop up the pieces and
just move on right you know it's not you
don't get quiet you try not to get red
face you get louder and you get louder
you just it's like well that yeah that
happened and it's over you know what
let's just move on yeah and but I didn't
say that next round's on me I just acted
like that hold it tight everybody
so I lit legitimately that's how I coped
I was like I'm gonna I'm gonna
demonstrate how you move on from an
embarrassing well yeah what are you
gonna do walk away right well droop your
head and just well slink back it is it
is the instincts it is fitting bury your
face in a napkin perhaps it's fitting
that you're telling me wrong story uh
about an embarrassing social situation
that we will now reference you know for
years come
um because
one of the things that I the the show
that I watched an entire season of
oh let me let me first of all
I I wasn't just sick I had coveted I
haven't I haven't said can we say that
it's just one of those things that for
some reason nobody said that you had
covet
well I want to talk about it because So
Good Mythical evening when I when I knew
you were sick you did obviously you
didn't know you had it well to be I want
to be clear because we're we're very
responsible around here so when I got so
Jesse got cold symptoms this is the
second time this has happened first of
all Jesse got cold symptoms on
like earlier in the week like Sunday
night Monday
and uh
this is also the same thing that
happened last year we made love
um great and I and uh as we do often and
uh this you know I was involved repeated
coughing on one another no are you into
that I didn't I there was no uh there
was no Lip lip to lip kissing for that
reason because it was just like a little
bit of a cold at the time right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you need not
kiss right and uh it need not be a part
of it well it usually is but when she's
like they don't kiss me not
and then she goes on to basically have a
very mild cold
she's super religious about not about
that but about testing for covid
and uh so when she got sick she tested
uh twice we've got tests at home just
like we've got a bunch of tests here
okay tested negative twice so I was like
okay it's not covered so then on like
Thursday day of GMM it was really like
Wednesday night like I'm starting to
feel a little bit oh damn I'm getting
that cold that Jesse got
so I tested that morning tested negative
and that's when I like texted you got
you and Brian and Steven I was like well
[__] I've got a cold
obviously we're not gonna not do it's
not coveted I tested I got it from Jesse
she tested twice negative right and so
we're good to go now by Thursday night I
don't know if it was obvious I felt like
horseshit all throughout a good mythical
evening it was like it was not obvious
it was getting worse
and um but I was like I gotta pull
through you sound worse now you didn't
sound
because it was the early stage right you
did good and uh you were drunk
and then yeah that did help well it
helped in the moment to feel bad
right when covet is actually setting in
I think I might have covet probably not
the best idea hammered so like Friday I
got real bad Friday night I had a fever
Saturday morning I wake up and I test
again I'm like I gotta test again
because I got a fever now
and positive and not just positive like
it looked like
somebody took a red Sharpie and went
across the control the uh you know the
sample part of the okay the other second
line besides the control line on the
test and I was like what am it's the
same test it's quote Usher You Got It
Bad yeah and for some reason this didn't
show up underneath that new strain going
around whatever and then it proceeded to
make me pretty damn sick just like last
time same pattern she actually gets a
cold we make love
she doesn't get of course last time she
got Co she knew that she had coveted
eventually and it was a pretty bad call
but for me it was worse like multi-day
fever aches I believe then I got it
from you no I think you got it from
somewhere else the timing based
Valentine yeah yeah yeah but anyways
going around again you know we're in the
midst of like the surge or whatever yeah
and once you tested positive that's why
I was like man I'm glad
I feel horrible for you I felt horrible
for it like because we've been really
you know we're we're very strict around
here about if you've got symptoms you
you don't come into work you you or you
well you you put on a mask if you're
going to be around and uh
so I just felt bad I was like man I
expose a lot of people so we had to do
the thing where like we say you know
there was an exposure I think everybody
knew it was me just because I mean
everybody was getting sick and uh
but so far it seems like it we got it
was we got away yeah
um yeah so
but anyway
I had to basically hold myself up in
Lock's room
uh I mean during the day I would go
because you know locks in college he's
got a TV in there and it's just like
we have some friends staying with us and
so I was like and then Shepard hasn't
had it yet so I was like I'm gonna spend
most of my time in here and I'll just
force myself to do what I hate to do
which is to relax and watch things you
know it's hard for me to just let go and
do that but
um I'm gonna tell you about some movies
I watch but I'm going to tell you mostly
about the fact that I watched all of
season three of Dave
little dickies yeah show which I know
you're also a fan of I haven't finished
this this season I'm not gonna spoil
anything
well I'm going to tell you one
incidental scene that has nothing to do
with anything plot related uh that
informs something from your past
oh really in any way so oh by the way
just so we're all clear
when we're recording this I've now
tested negative three times
and so I'm no longer contagious I've got
like this residual like cough and this
is where my voice is still kind of
affected but you know that'll probably
be happening for a few days
but
um
you know I think that first of all we're
both huge fans of the show Dave we just
we we we love the way that
just the sort of surreal comedy nature
of it right and now you have your
experience that you had with with Dave
bird Little Dicky in real life right
where we were at a party it was you and
I and Stevie and I told the story on
here but to keep it short yeah yeah so I
was like are you little Dicky he said
wait so the way that it worked was is
that link uh tends to uh uh just go up
to People by himself I mean sometimes
it's part of a sometimes it's a
strategic plan but a lot of times it's
just like the three of us will be
talking and then you'll just kind of
leave and go start talking to people it
means Stevie would keep talking to each
other and I look up and you're talking
to little Dave and then we find out
little Dave Little Dicky in the
conversation was yeah he said hi I'm
Dave and I said oh
I thought you were a little Dicky and he
was like
I am but you that's not my real name
you know Jay-Z's real name is not Jay-Z
and I was like yeah I did I just I was
just when I got I was thinking when I
got close to you you didn't look like
the Little Dicky that I thought from far
away but I didn't say that about that
time was when it's kind of in a CV and I
walked up and you were kind of
explaining what happened and then Dave
said to you do you remember exactly what
he said
he said I remember the exact words
because this is doing good no he said
you're doing great
he said you're doing great you're doing
great because I you know I was kind of
explaining yourself I was embarrassed he
said you're doing great I didn't I I
wasn't doing as great as I did when I
spilled the stuff on Lincoln's crotch
see I've learned now I have more cool
now than I did then when we told that
story I was not doing great when we told
that story the first time yes the show
had not come out showing that come out
Dave
I want to say that I think we told that
story
and it kind of made him seem like an
[__]
yes okay I mean at least very snarky
like you're doing great like mocking you
yes
it was reassuring but in a and I thought
a mocking kind of way it wasn't mocking
oh yeah it wasn't mocking I've watched
enough of this show now I know that the
show yeah I know that the show
is not exactly the guy okay
but my theory he says that line my
theory is that he's not an [__] no I
don't think he's okay no I think he's a
knight now watch the show now I I think
he's great I think he's a thoughtful guy
I think he also is
an awkward guy yeah I think about
Kindred Spirits I think he's also an
awkward guy because there's there's
literally
Mo there's literally at least one party
scene in this season where he's kind of
demonstrating the fact that he doesn't
know how to navigate a party okay now
that's an unrelated scene I'm just
thinking about that right now okay
but there is a scene in which a fan an
awkward fan
comes up to him
and is kind of you know doing the thing
that people do sometimes they don't know
what what to say and they start saying
things yeah and he says you're doing
great
and he says it in a way that is actually
like he's you know
it's endearing and I replay the whole
story through my mind again and I think
that he actually was just trying to tell
you that like it's fine man it's fine
like the fact that you didn't know
it's it's funny we're all good it's fine
you're doing great I don't think he was
mocking you whatsoever I think that I
believe that actually just trying to
defuse the situation yeah and I think we
both kind of misinterpreted it but do
you think I was doing great
you're doing great man no I wasn't
that was the disconnect no you weren't
doing great but he was basically hey his
you're not doing great means it's okay
but it's okay that's okay
it's okay man
huh uh I'm gonna feel weird when I watch
that even if even though you've told me
about it you spoiled that for me but I'm
still gonna feel weird when I watch it
you know so you I don't want to talk you
legitimately believe I spoiled something
for you a detail well you spoiled that
experience for me of like the blood
leaving my body you know what when he
when he says you're doing great oh my
God he said that to me is this whole
thing about me you wouldn't have
remembered it I bet I bet my life I
would have remembered it you would no
because you didn't even remember what he
said you would that you would it would
have gone you see you're doing he said
okay whatever you wouldn't have
remembered it man okay now you're gonna
watch it with appreciation
uh By the Way season three great All
Season's great I love that show I love
the way they do that I love the choices
they make in the final episode oh gosh
that's what I'm hearing
I mean it's been built up now Ben built
it up for me I'm building it up for you
so you'd probably be a little bit
disappointed
which is worse than me spoiling with one
detail in one scene yeah
but
yeah man it's inspirational from a
creative standpoint you know
but
I did also did the thing where uh
what the nothing
you're doing great
uh you know what you're doing I also did
the thing yeah whoever says you're doing
great first wins you know because it's
like it I do understand how it make it
it seems like a power play it does seem
like a power play but I don't think
that's what he was doing
I did that thing where you
um yeah I don't think it you're like I'm
gonna watch I'm gonna watch movie I'm
gonna watch some movies
and I'm gonna watch some movies that
yeah
um I've thought I've thought this a lot
over the past I'm gonna watch movies
that I feel like as a person in
professional entertainment I should have
watched yeah you got time on your hands
and I know what you're about to say and
I'm gonna watch movies that people are
like you gotta watch this movie for the
it's like for the sake of the history of
Cinema you need to watch this movie like
being there
no no keep keep going in reverse brother
all right happy Madison
I'm older oh oh going to reverse I
thought what you were going to say was
you didn't end up watching any movies
because you realize you don't like
watching movies Happy Madison is not a
movie that's yeah it is Billy Madison Oh
Happy Gilmore Happy Madison is the name
of this production company okay whatever
um I'm doing great
um did you actually watch a movie
because that's what I was calling you on
that you actually realized didn't want
to watch a movie I watched at least five
oh gosh that's so hard now
I was sick for a while it's hard it's
hard to watch movies is all I'm saying
because now we have all these other
things that you can watch that take less
time and it's a perceived smaller
commitment to sit down and watch a movie
is it you know what I don't do it
anymore it's just too much to handle
movies are a thing of the past well I
think maybe you haven't opened yourself
up to the way that you can get through a
movie in 2023
with a phone in hand oh and the phone in
hand I feel too guilty to the movie no
my phone my phoning during the movie was
all related to the movie
okay it was like x-ray it was like
Amazon x-ray but it was in my hand
I had a Diet Coke in one hand in my
phone on the other hand they never
touched
oh it did great
what did you watch Citizen Kane no you
didn't why that's so dumb it's not dumb
it's not when you have seen it I saw it
in the intro to film class okay okay
well hold up I mean the editing was
inventive but now it's just like oh it
was editing you know it's like you you
have to you have to understand what
didn't exist before it to appreciate it
but who cares when you read about it
first yeah you have to read about it and
but so that was the exercise the
exercise wasn't like I just want to be
entertained the process was I'm sick
I've just I sounded nothing like me I've
just watched a whole season of a
television show not was it this was a
different day
I'm gonna watch stuff that feels like
I'm like you know I want to learn some
stuff
you want to achieve something so why do
people care about this movie why was
this considered that why is this on
every list of the best movies of all
time
um why was it considered the best the
best movie of all time for decades and
then I'm like oh 1941 Orson Welles he
wrote it he directed it he starred in it
he produced it it's kind of crazy okay
you know at least so
uh and then as I watched it I like
would Google things about the different
people or whatever yeah because it's so
freaking boring uh I mean it's
definitely you don't you can't recommend
it in the way that you would recommend
like a movie like a movie that you want
people to watch like man this movie's
gonna blow you away of course it's not
gonna blow you away it's from 1941 but
like in context with a phone you have to
have a phone okay and a Diet Coke
uh I was glad that I did it but then I
didn't turn around and then be like I'm
gonna now I'm gonna go watch uh like
I didn't watch Charlie Chaplin's City
Lights man I didn't go I didn't go
silent film I almost did but after doing
Citizen Kane I was like okay I don't
know if I could take Charlie Chaplin I
uh I'll save that for the next time I
get covered I'll save that for next year
um but then I but then I stayed on that
list of like influential I don't know I
looked at a couple of different lists
then I went to
um
Mulholland Drive which I had seen before
Nick Nolte no no no David Lynch David
Lynch movie uh that's actually got um
the dude from
uh the HBO show uh
The Leftovers
that guy Justin Thoreau okay uh
uh well first of all David Lynch man
like this that
David David Lynch makes like weird
movies
uh it's got
um what's her name
uh for the the Naomi Watts in it too and
then some other okay so this isn't that
old uh no it's like 20 23 years old and
there's a there's a a lesbian sex scene
in it if that interests you
um I would say yes it does and uh
anyway that one was weird and I was just
kind of like I get it I it was it was
it's okay but like there's just no heart
in it so I just was like I
I don't think I would this is not like
in my top favorite movies just because
I'm not laughing at anything on purpose
and I'm not there's no heart in it it's
just weird okay you know what I'm saying
so then I was like okay what next
let's get a little bit more modern I'm
gonna watch that Nick Cage vampire movie
oh yeah Renfield there you go
and uh can you recommend it
Rosebud I think maybe I was moved out by
this time it's hard to watch a movie
because can I say I was just kind of
like I this I was hoping for more it
definitely wasn't as good as that uh
Nick Cage Pedro Pascal Movie that that
was perfect can I just say one more time
movies are dying they're too long
they're too long you need to break them
up in new episodes
or reduce them to like 15 second pithy
clips
that can be scrolled vertically
but as it stands they're dying well
they're gone you know you can watch it
as a gimmick but hold on but you're not
going to enjoy it this is a company
don't have capacity for it anymore okay
first of all for I think you should
resist this it's over secondly movies
are over this doesn't happen in the
theaters and I won't let my creative
business partner who co-owns my
entertainment company with me say that
movies are over but I'm just you know
what are you saying that as half of
Rhett and Link are you saying that is
only link I'm saying that as somebody
who's just trying to get a
little clip-on tick tock
oh okay let me know in the comments if
you agree with me
well movies are done
I disagree with you and I here's the
thing you know what I also disagree
here's the thing
you watch it with a phone if you're
watching it at home which the thing that
and I don't mean this for every movie
there's lots of movies that I don't need
a phone for I mean Citizen Kane
I mean anything before 1950 you got to
give me a phone I gotta have a
connection to the modern world again
tell me why this should be good but the
the other piece of it is I think that uh
if you're like a gen Z person this is
how you watch things already and
I was you know how like sometimes you'd
like make a video or we make something
and you want to like show it to somebody
like oh there's a new video that we've
been working on and you'll show it to
your wife or your kids or whatever okay
yeah and if they're on their phone it's
like oh gosh get off your phone look at
this masterpiece I've made every detail
was intentional I just thought about how
filmmakers the idea of somebody being on
their phone while something important is
being said no that's why I don't know
every single second but this doesn't
happen in the theater man theaters
you're comfortable you're laid back you
don't need you can't be on your phone in
the theater anyway yeah
movies at home are dying I'd like to
make an amendment movies at home are
dying
in a theater
they'll they'll go on a few more years
few more years and I'm here for it um
okay so anyway what's your wreck Citizen
Kane no my have I have we have we we
probably recommended Dave as a show
before already I'll do it again but I'll
recommend season three okay and you do
need to start with season one and two
all right but yeah I just you know you
gotta watch it if if if you if you like
I mean we're not doing anything like it
on the Rhett and Link channel in a sense
but that I feel like
the same place that they're coming from
creatively I like to think that they're
accessing a similar
um inspirational space well there's
Creative Juice that's a narrative
creative that's a narrative thing but
like they're making choices because they
like the choices that they're being made
and they're trying to say something
that's another layer deeper than just
the thing that they're showing you I I
thought season three was a little slow
but I'm I'm hanging on for the part that
was inspired by me
okay yeah I did I don't believe it was I
just believe we've now learned this is
something that Dave bird says when uh in
situations where he feels like somebody
might be embarrassed about what they're
saying or doing he likes to say you're
doing great you're doing great yeah yeah
no I was thinking to you you're doing
great and you know what you've done
great
because you made it to the end of this
ear biscuit let us know what you think
uh by interacting with us using hashtag
your biscuits or leaving us a voicemail
I love it when you leave us a voicemail
1-88
earpod one
hey Rhett and Link My name is Abby
um I just have to say my Google Maps
glitched out as I was listening to your
1984 episode of the Pod and I got to
listen to YouTube berate us Millennials
for not knowing how to use paper maps
while I took several wrong turns with my
glitched out Google Maps fine you're
right we rely on technology rub it in
why don't you thanks for everything you
do love the Pod bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]